we're learning additional details
tonight about plans for police reform
and the epicenter of the movement
Minnesota correspondent Matt Finn is in
st. Paul tonight we would like to end
the current policing system as we know
it Minneapolis City Council unanimously
passed a resolution today laying the
foundation for dismantling the police
department and transforming the city's
public safety system the winds of change
I never would have imagined it would be
where we are right now I'm uniting
behind this the resolution says police
use of force is among the leading causes
of death for young men of color and cost
the city 24 million dollars in
settlements the past three years people
many of us are tired of protesting in
the streets every time police kill
someone in our community the City
Council wants to stop police from
responding to certain 911 calls but the
police chief tells Fox News he's going
to make sure ongoing discussions are
fact driven because 911 calls his
officers are responding to our quote
life-saving we are going to continue to
show up I am NOT going to allow this
Police Department to abandon those
people within our communities who still
rely upon us and need us in Louisville
Kentucky City Council voted Thursday to
ban no-knock warrants and Senator Rand
Paul introduced a bill to end them
nationwide as well after 26 year-old
emergency medical technician Brianna
Taylor was shot by police while unarmed
in her apartment during a no-knock
warrant in March
ariana wanted to do was save lives so
it's important is law passes because
with that she'll get to continue to do
that even in her death and in Chicago 13
police officers are under investigation
after video emerged showing them making
popcorn drinking coffee and sleeping in
u.s. representative Bobby Russia's
ransacked office while nearby businesses
were allegedly being looted at the same
time in Minneapolis right now hundreds
of protesters are outside of the police
union building once again demanding its
controversial president resigned and
then also happening right
now here in st. Paul there's an ongoing
special session but so far no major
movement on police reform Brett - live
in st. Paul man thanks